[Musik]
hallo herzlich willkommen so salis welt
heute gibt es ein super leckeres rezept
wir werden nämlich stakes zubereiten mit
einer gemüsepfanne und einer senfsauce
über moral lisa li na ja heute gibt es
selbst mit senfsauce ich muss dazu sagen
ich habe bei murat extra dicke stacks
bestellt aber er wisse ja der murat ist
schwabe also hat er ja ich habe
erfahrung mitgebracht muss ehrlich sagen
ich habe diesen diesen werten herrn habe
ich wirklich gesagt bitte mach mit dicke
steaks und der hat mir mal der schwabe
naja schwäbische türke ich glaube ich
glaube das ist ein dickes tag das ist ja
aber wachsen schnitzel ja aber ich kann
nicht sagen ich mich jetzt nicht also
ich freu mich halt genommen
normalerweise alles unter 3 cm ist
wahrhaftig ein carpaccio
also ich weiß egal wir kriegen daraus
auch in schweinefleisch stück für dich
hin
und dazu gibt es eine gemüsepfanne die
machen wir richtig schön bunt und die
senfsauce selbstlose ist sowas richtig
einfach ist und ich zeige euch jetzt so
erst einmal die zutaten für die
gemüsepfanne und danach für die sendung
genial wie die zutaten muss mal kurz aus
ausgehen
ihr seht ist noch waschen dafür
fleischstück genau man lieber mal das
war nacken nacken
warum ruft natürlich wo sonst fällt
gerade sagen ja harmlos und testen
ok und hier sind ja auch ich bin dass
diese diese diese marmorierung dieses
ding hier dieses fett hier dieses genial
was als dann wirklich ist es ist
wirklich zu dieser zeit ja ja dann kann
es noch jetzt zeigen und ist jetzt ist
es jetzt echt viel zu tun das müssen wir
ein bisschen dicker sein 15 genau wenn
es mich wenn es nicht antrat ist oder
halt ist allgemein dann gilt es noch ein
bisschen morath aber ich zeige jetzt
erstmal die zutaten für die gemüsepfanne
denn zuerst muss das ganze gemüse
geputzt und geschnitten werden
für die gemüsepfanne verwende ich 60
milliliter rapsöl eine knoblauchzehe 2
karotten habe ich braune champignons ein
brokkoli einen kredit bei spitz paprika
eine gelbe paprika einstellungen
rosmarin 200 g
recht bohnen oder buschbohnen hier habe
ich etwas neues aus der dose und salz
und pfeffer für die selbstlose brauche
ich 40 gramm butter 40 familien jeweils
250 milliliter gemüsebrühe oder weit
sein
hier habe ich die sahne drei bis vier
esslöffel senf dann nämlich einem
grobkörnigen etwas zitronensaft und salz
und pfeffer zum abschmecken
damit alles gleich zeitgleich fertig ist
werde ich jetzt erst einmal das gemüse
so haben jetzt schon gewaschen
ich werde jetzt klein schneiden zuerst
nämlich jetzt die knoblauchzehe die
schneide ich einfach in feine scheiben
[Musik]
und die kann ich schon mal hier im öl
anbraten so bekommt das öl einfach so
ein leichtes und schönes knoblauch aroma
jetzt bereite ich zuerst das gemüse mit
der längsten garzeit so das heißt die
karotten und die bohnen
[Musik]
und das restliche gemüse schneidet ihr
dann einfach so wie es euch am besten
gefällt
die spitz paprika zum beispiel in ringe
den brokkoli ein bisschen fein und die
zucchini in hall beschreiben
[Musik]
jetzt kommen die bohnen und karotten
hier mit in die pfanne und werden ein
bisschen angebraten und ihr müsst
einfach dann selber entscheiden wie
bisher ist oder wie weiche das gemüse
haben wollt ich gebe dann als nächstes
den brokkoli dazu verbraucht nämlich
auch ein bisschen länger als die paprika
und die champignons und vor allem auch
länger als die zucchini
[Musik]
jetzt kann ich hier den topf bereits
erhitzen für die soße die soße wenn
jetzt nämlich auch angesetzt und dafür
gebe ich jetzt die putzer hier rein
gemeinsam mit dem mehl und kann das
ganze anschwitzen und an der stelle
könnt ihr jetzt auch das fleisch
anbraten
ich mache das jetzt hier in meiner
reisen falle da brauche ich das fleisch
mit etwas butter schmalz an und gibt es
dann in den backofen so dass es schön
medium ist
[Musik]
und die mehlschwitze da jetzt ein
bisschen hellbraun werden
[Musik]
hier gebe ich jetzt zwischendurch noch
den deckel drauf wegen brokkoli dass da
ein bisschen weiter wird
[Musik]
sobald die mehlschwitze etwas hellbraun
ist kann ich sehr ablöschen mit
gemüsebrühe oder mit etwas weißwein zum
beispiel da kommt auch direkt die sahne
mit rein lässt ist er leichter haben
will nimmt milch jetzt kann ich die
sauce aufkochen und dann ein bisschen
einkochen lassen
mit salz und pfeffer würzen aber jetzt
noch keinen senf dazu geben denn wenn
der erhitzt wird ein katheter support
den geschmack also der kommt erst am
schluss dazu und die pfanne gebe ich
jetzt hier nach und nach die restliche
gemüse mit rein
[Musik]
jetzt kenne ich die soße würzen da kommt
jetzt ein bisschen zitronensaft rein für
die säure wenn ihr weißwein benutzt kann
es auch sein dass er gar keinen
zitronensaft bedeutet dann salz pfeffer
wenn ich die soße zu fisch zubereitet
dann kann man da zum beispiel auch dill
dazugeben passt auch perfekt zur
senfsauce und jetzt stelle ich die
temperatur herunter hat damit einfach
der senf nicht mit kocht und gb ziert
den senf dazu und damals sind die chance
genommen im grobkörnigen um einem auf
die ist die ganzen meist stückchen
[Musik]
jetzt noch das gemüse salzen und
pfeffern und dann kommt hier noch der
meister zu und dann ist immer fertig
[Musik]
oliver morath du darfst probieren das
fleisch muss man natürlich auch salzen
und pfeffern
ich habe jetzt halt noch kleine
stückchen drauf weil jetzt weiter foto
teller ok also moderne zuschauern nur
das es ist wenn ich das foto teller ist
dann das essen immer kalt so okay das
ist mal nicht so murat immer mo hat das
wichtigste ist okay aber trotzdem und
das andere was ich was ich jetzt zu
kritisieren
im light assist zu kritisieren die
tester kritisiert vor allem dass das
fleisch ja und ich mag das echte aber
für die fotos ist hat ja du sagst du ich
habe sagt halt immer wieder
ich mache das gesellenstück ich mag es
wenn ich nächstes fleisch selber
ansteigen wird okay ich nur sagen aber
das ist jetzt ihr nicht böse gemeint
hatte nichts mit liebst du das nächste
mal auch stronach ist echt genial dieser
selbstlose koch jetzt noch nudeln ab für
samira nämlich und brokkoli und da ist
halt einfach nur wichtig dass wir eben
einen guten senf nimmt also dieser die
chance 11 der grobkörnige jetzt der
feine aus hannover der passt nicht so
wirklich dazu und dementsprechend
schmeckt die soße dann auch und
abschmecken müsst das einfach nach
eigenem belieben wie gesagt mit weißwein
mit gemüsebrühe mit zitrone was auch
immer ihr möchtet wir kochen uns jetzt
noch die nudeln ab das gemüse auch schön
bist und es ist halt wirklich super
schnell gemacht also wenn ihr mal
schneller soße haben wollt ist die
selbstlose wirklich ideal darf sie jetzt
noch dein brokkoli holen aus dem
kühlschrank
du darfst den tisch decken ich habe die
aufgaben verteilt ich mache noch nudeln
für uns und ich würde aber sagen was ich
wollte ja ich habe mich noch nie so eine
geniale symbiose jetzt gut ist so lecker
ja und die passt dann auch kurz um
gemüse zu fisch zu allem lecker
schmecker euro
noch die frage noch nicht ist eine
zuschauer auch fragen und zwar begann
kann so eine selbstlose aufbewahren
eigentlich bin ich sollte man es sofort
essen denn der sense kommt ihr erst zum
schluss dazu damit einfach der geschmack
nicht verloren geht wenn selbst zum
beispiel kochgeschmack sofort weg und
deswegen nur nach dem kochen ganz kurz
dazu gehören und dann sofort sanieren
aber die schnell gemacht muss man nicht
aufheben
also viel spaß beim nachkochen wir
setzen uns jetzt auch alle zum essen und
ich wünsche euch viel spaß dabei in
guten appetit bis zum nächsten mal
komm wir suchen eine mauer coli er ist
eben anderen kühlschrank
[Musik]